Reggie Miller Hall of Famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst reg will be calling
the Eastern Conference Finals for TN T
it'll be the Cavs against the either the
Celtics of the Wizards my Wizards get
blown out again these are two evenly
matched teams but the margin of victory
has been 16 point why I such a disparity
there reg between these two it's like if
you're at home you're winning and you're
winning big line yeah look I was
surprised at last night's outcome I
thought we would you know especially
with the series tied 2-2 those game
fires are usually ones for the ages and
for Boston and I give Boston all the
credit it's surprising because you're
right both teams are evenly matched
personally I think Washington has
probably a little bit more talent but in
my opinion Boston probably has the heart
and you would think the games would be
closer and they have been at times but
they've been a game of runs if you've
seen some of the trends that have gone
on in this series whether it's Boston
going on a 2600 run last night Boston
went on I believe a 16 over run yeah so
it's a little head scratching at times
but uh at the day does it really matter
I'm just going to do I was going to ask
you who would give Cleveland a better
you know matchup is it fair to say no
one really I mean look I think with
Washington those guards are fantastic in
John Wall Bradley bill I think you have
a few players possibly that can you know
play LeBron James and Markieff Morris
maybe Otto Porter I think for Boston you
have a lot of guys defensively mark a
smart Crowder Avery Bradley Isiah Thomas
has been fantastic in these playoffs
especially the whole story that
surrounds you know the death of his
sister and what they've overcome
emotionally physically being down Oh -
and everyone thinking that series is
over and then Rhonda
you know the injury and then they go on
to win four straight but really I I
don't see anyone really challenging you
know Cleveland in the East I think
people are trying to take LeBron down a
little bit on his pedestal there by
saying you know who is he really
defeated and but if he beats Golden
State this year then then there are no
more excuses for LeBrons greatness I not
that he no he's great I just it feels
like they're still looking for something
to take him down a notch or two
was it last week or two weekends ago I
said you can make a case if LeBron James
wins this year and they go through
Golden State I didn't say if it was the
right case but you could make a case
that he is neck and neck with the goat
Michael Jordan the times was seven
straight times if he does make it knock
on wood it'll work to be done but we're
assuming he's going to get to the finals
yeah that would be seven straight and
what they overcame last year being down
3-1 and if they go through Golden State
again which we're assuming it will be
Golden State you can make a case that
he's on the same plane pedestal as
Michael Jordan people may say I'm wrong
which is fine but I'm saying you can
make a case it might be the wrong case
but you can make a cake well I think and
I agree with you if you go through
Golden State now you've gone through one
of the great lineups in NBA history
you've defeated San Antonio you've
defeated Oklahoma City when they had
Durant harden and Westbrook but this
would be I think the one that now all of
a sudden you're getting people's
attention about this you beat Golden
State last year being down 3-1 and a
team that won 73 games most ever they go
out and get arguably the second best
player in the world in Kevin Durant and
then you find a way to go through them
again that's I mean that's huge on your
resume you would have to now people are
going to say look you know he lost in
San Antonio in the finals he lost to
Dallas in the finals
and you know Michael Jordan was perfect
and I get that that's why to me Michael
went six one six six finals MVP that
trumps to me that trumps just about
everything but seven straight times to
the finals and what I just highlighted
he has overcome you can make a case
he's Reggie Miller Reggie old called the
Eastern Conference Finals the cabs
waiting for the Celtics of the Wizards
Kevin Durant said that if he were coming
into the league and going to be drafted
he would not go to the NBA combine what
do you think of them I don't see what
the disadvantage you know Kevin Durant
was going to be a top he should have
been number one but obviously Greg Oden
went there look it's a chance for teams
to I guess you know not only do their
background checks but to get early
information on you I don't understand
when I was coming out they didn't have
the combines what we did is I believe we
went to which was great Maui and know
all the players went to Maui and they
just basically played pickup games and
all the scouts were there and this was
through the NBA and that's how they kind
of evaluated you now they've kind of
taken it a step further and kind of
doing what the NFL does what the
combines where they measure you and you
know your reach and your how big your
hands are how faster I guess they do
agility drills shooting so it's just a
way for them to get background on you
that's all I don't think there's you
know any detriment for a player going I
think it's helped players actually get
drafted but players that are going to be
lottery picks is it beneficial maybe not
there's enough tape out on them but
those those guys that are mid-majors
that you've heard a lot about but you
haven't seen a lot in his chance for
everyone in one room in one arena to get
a chance to evaluate Alonzo ball is not
going to go but marquel folds is and
folds is expected to be the number one
pick overall again he probably won't do
a lot of the basketball agility stuff
but he'll go there and get measured
because there's you get your official
measurement as well exactly how tall you
really are because guys lie you know
everyone says they're six nine six ten
and then
show up and they're like six four did
you lie no my height tells it speaks for
itself Theodore no no your weight your
weight did you lie about your way I do I
did like I didn't like all that weight I
told our one idea then when they looked
at me they were like you've got to be
kidding me
Olive Oyl you are not my - well what
were you 175 170 170 160 nine ish I was
on the Michael Cooper diet at the time
what was your official height six seven
like three-quarter six seven so I round
up to six seven six seven 176 seven 190
can you believe that how did I make it
18 years seriously how did I mean what
was great is at UCLA they always push
for me to lift waist you're getting a
bigger lift weights lift weights as soon
as I got to the league Jack Ramsey was
like don't even pick up a weight
push-ups pull-ups sit-ups that's it I
was like cool all right let's go but
that really became my diet of workouts
but I also remember that they worried
about how you ran that was that a story
done yes I wore braces until I was the
age of five
both of my feet pronated out so I had to
wear braces to bring my feet in so they
would be regular so on my right knee it
it's almost like a 45-degree angle so
teams and physicians were worried that I
was going to have an ACL injury or have
knee problems or back issues but I ran
like a deer it was great because once I
got out of the braces when I was a kid
and I was able to you know run with you
know Saul Durrell and Sheryl and Tammy
the last thing on my mind was worried
about a knee injury or a back injury I
was just glad to be out of the braces so
I always prided myself on conditioning
so I ran so much as a kid it never
became an issue once I started playing
tyronn lue says it the calves and
warriors feels like the Celtics and late
of the 80s you agree I do I do agree and
you know I know LeBron came out less
than a year ago and saying it's not a
rivalry oh it's definitely a rivalry
especially if they meet this third time
to trilogy you know it would be great
right now
both teams have been off well over a
week they should have a practice game
they should have a secret game seriously
if I'm draymond Green I would call us
with Ronda and James and say look let's
meet in the middle between San Francisco
and Cleveland let's just have an
exhibition because this is what I'm this
is what I'm in fear of because both
teams still have some work to do I fear
one of the key players is going to get
hurt in the conference finals and then
we're going to have the all the excuses
well nutsedge got hurt and right now
both teams are holding both teams are
probably playing their best game I just
have a pickup game you know it doesn't
have to be publicized let's meet in the
middle what's in between Cleveland poly
what's in between Cleveland and San
Francisco what state Oh what state is
absolutely in the middle Nebraska let's
meet in the middle and have an
exhibition game right now right now yes
on y'all Jim yeah RJ yeah let's go yeah
let's go Creighton University is going
to host the warriors against their
Cavallari did you hear this Steve Harvey
story I have not okay
he put happen they put out a memo for
his his staff he's going into his fifth
season of The Steve Harvey Show and he
basically said don't talk to me don't
make eye contact don't come into my
dressing room
don't ambush me when I walk in the
hallway so the memo from a purple one
it's not kind of what friends used to do
like you couldn't look prints in the eye
or something like that
were you ever around somebody that that
you weren't allowed to do then you're
not well no no no come on that's crazy
come on and we don't no way only was
this actually a memo this actually went
out again so this is 1 over sent true
yeah Pauly do you have that memorandum
on oh look I've I've met Steve and
passing great guy for come all that I
could see I could see certain Hollywood
stars doing that well look we've heard
room
of you know the divas but you didn't
write you dare a prince I never never
met Prince I've never met Michael trying
to think who would be a real diva
I met JLo when she was dating um Ben
Affleck she threw him a party and I went
with Weitzel Patrick Whitesell um and
was the nicest person now I had heard
stories but uh she did you make eye
contact with jealousy it was dark and I
did um but she was nice to me but I
could see where people could perceive
where she could be somewhat of a diva I
could see that but she was nice to me so
I can only judge her by how she
interacted with me I think Mariah Carey
might be like that do you think yeah I
think so yes yeah I don't know and I'm
not going to speculate because you know
but if you could have met Prince or
Michael Jackson oh come on now all right
so I'm not even kalaiy no not even the
most you loved Michael I wanted to be a
Jackson but I wanted to be the first how
many Jacksons are there 95 I wanted to
be the 96 Jackson if you could have had
Latoya's career your career which career
would you want oh don't don't say I
would have been who is the how about how
would it be Randy I'm everyone loves us
have been Randy and we're talking I've
been Randy and we're talking about Randy
Jackson who's not related to the Jackson
family he was just on American Idol
right now that rule have another ready
Daniel I know
would you would you have traded places
with Tito yes absolutely
Tito already why could have been one of
them Saul and Kerri and Tito had game
two I mean he's good yeah he could play
he could play I took them two moves but
no MJ would have been my number one but
I I love the purple one - don't get me
wrong I would love to go to a club with
Prince and just probably hang out and
play video games with MJ again I don't
want to go to color I want to go to the
core
/ pretty he would have the the velvet
rope there Whitney there you go yeah but
who would did you go clubbing at all
when you played like who would you go
out with that you knew you liked you
weren't friends with Barkley right I was
we were very good friends back to today
oh so you would socially I thought you
were one of those I had a great way
during the season oh yeah the Olympic
Olympics that's one you know okay we
knew we were going to be teams by
30-plus so you know we made Atlanta fun
Rick you and Rick Smits going out
tearing up the town right the dunking
judgment Yeah right no occasion I will
go out with Mark Jackson my Davis voice
but you know you're there to work of
course you are there to work but that's
when I first I met you and Mark Jackson
when we smoked cigars in in our riveting
was that night it that was the best
night of probably ever just talking I
mean it just wasn't like isolated the
basketball we talked to everything all
night well but I didn't really know you
but I knew mark a little bit and then we
just got together and you guys didn't
agree on anything
everybody everybody had like one guy
locked like Marino one guy like Montana
I liked Rod Carew he likes to win yeah
it was like the best of it we couldn't
agree on one single thing other than
throw me the basketball and we'll win
that was the only thing we basically
agreed upon yeah mark you just back
people down throw me the ball and let me
score and get out of the way those were
the best times no meeting you that night
and that was fun sharing this carrying
this this friendship you know 20-plus
years now it's been fantastic he's going
to call the Eastern Conference Finals
and he's saying does it really matter
it's the Cavs against either the Celtics
are Wizards he's Reggie Aloysius Miller
reg thank you and we'll talk to you once
the conference final star Theodore you
are truly the best a net it was great
seeing you last week q
Reggie Miller he was having fun with ice
cube ice cube had security there the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience